mr. Bob okay baby stormy is jamming out
poolside this Easter weekend
her dad Travis sky capturing that
adorable video as he's quarantine with
her mom Kylie Jenner and glama Chris in
Palm Springs for the holiday don't know
Kylie shared this video on her incest
story of the group making some wood fire
pizza you can hear Travis in the
background trying to help I think I just
should leave it alone when it comes to
Kylie and Travis a source told ET back
in March that Kylie and Travis were
officially a couple again after their
split last October saying quote the
couple has always had love and respect
for one another but took a break last
year because they both had so much going
on
they couldn't fully focus on what it
took to make the relationship work
although things haven't slowed down much
for the duo they're better able to
handle it at the end of the day the
couple is happy to have their family
back together the beauty mogul is
obviously enjoying this family time she
posted some festive treats
she created captioning one pick I've
been on a roll
at one point stormy was not feeling the
weather in Palm Springs but based off
Kylie's and sis Tories the rain
eventually cleared up and the to hit the
pool last month et spoke with Caitlyn
Jenner about how much kylie is enjoying
quarantine because she gets to spend it
with stormy I think he's happy because
she's at home and spending a lot of time
with stormy and she loves that body
Kendall likes getting out but she loves
being at home she loves cooking loves
being you know a little stormy and she's
doing just fine when it comes to stormy
having little brothers and sisters in
the future
Kylie revealed her plans to make that
happen last week on Instagram lies
another baby Kylie I don't want another
baby right now but I want like seven
kids but not right now I'm like anyone f
you but of course I want like I wish I
could snap my fingers but pregnancy is
just not a it's it's the way pregnancy
is set up it's not a joke it's a serious
thing and it's hard well I'm not ready
for that right now
[Music]